I've been working out more than I've
ever worked out and I don't nothing
grows nothing is what I mean either I
mean dude I read I wrote 10 miles on my
[ __ ] bike this is a big boys bike
club Wow
it's a movement yeah worldwide movement
you're welcome movement can't be part of
it mundo don't say anymore man it's
making me mad a worldwide mr. worldwide
known alright fine
whoo hey all right all over the place
boy bike we're riding in every city it's
a huge matter
that's insane jerseys and stick around
everybody you guys are in a good fight
group you know [ __ ] bikers so many of
us oh look at you responding okay
sick of you biking well you're posting a
[ __ ] picture of your stupid bike dude
stupid you think the specialized
Stumpjumper stupid what is it that pig
is how do you fat [ __ ] pig for the
next picture how are you on that stupid
little seat what's wrong look at your
face look at me dude man you got all you
got a lot of meat on your face jacked I
do have a lot of meat so happy you're
the next ones your lips dude
bassy ten miles look at that hey Matt
speed your fat pig at 40 miles an hour
all right but listen 39b
listen this daddy's moving I know but
like it's a movement it's a movement so
annoying do you want me to be part of it
you can't hey asking you you're looking
at the I'm the I'm asking
don't be shitty let me ask not give me
shitty okay don't be shitty brand me
your best pitch to get it first of all
hey let me just ask you this do we have
cover requirement yeah do you have a
mountain bike now I don't know hold on
hold on not looking good I want to buy a
Stumpjumper you want a specialized thumb
jump now I would avoid 6161 that that's
actual arch now they're not giving that
away right expansive or not too bad well
I don't know what your budget is what
would be a good what is a good mountain
bike cost um jump like 400 bucks
bring matter do you not want to get in
the club ha
is that what you're doing $400 hold on
your bikes gonna fall apart at 400 let
me see what this bet that's expensive
you think is the game plan
I don't know I don't know do you think I
can be the leader of the thick boy
look let me like let me get a let me
California chapter and you think we have
a foreigner I got a starter bike and I
go get myself a little special a good
starter one me get a regular mountain
bike and then let me join them eight
hundred dollars
I'll start start lifting and start
working out I'll eat more let me be in
the thick where are you on a bike how
you up hills not asking that I got the
heart of a lion not asking that how am i
up hills yes cross-country trail I'm
strong like don't worry about me did you
go to Mountain yeah these do trail I
wouldn't worry about me I'll hang I'll
hang that's a video there we go stroll
down hold on don't go to stump jumpers -
is too advanced for Brad uh you know
what I like for Brian oh god I wish do
the Rockhopper
now scroll down
and how much is the Rockhopper for the
old man just maybe just type in
specialized rock opera cuz this is just
the hair thing you can shop it yeah now
I'm gonna take you to real world where I
got mine real world will world behind so
out bad I'm in business I'm in business
dude between five and seven hundred
bucks in my suit we can get you on the
mountain all right yeah rough right
where I go yeah it's me a rough ride for
a rough ride rough ride we got some
rocks and Hills fat pig I'm telling it's
me a little laughing now there's a pink
one
well let's not pee maybe I'll get the
door I'll get sick boy on my [ __ ]
bike know what what I'm asking dude
you're barking up the tree and getting a
fat pig didn't come down on the [ __ ] you
up keep talking this [ __ ] dude hold on
hey there's a lot of thick boys out
there I am say and we're pretty United
and I don't like the way you are in man
I'm just saying I wanna let me let me
buck in here you can buck in yeah you
can buck it hey guys what you up to let
me pay guys
I'll wear my thick boy sweatshirt what's
going on no big boy by club stickers
coming out and you put on your bike now
keep this in mind no I'm gonna charge
extra
you're not thick 3% surge now hole I
keep this in my jack you guys are all
thick you call it Jack's mom built for
mountain biking so if I could if I pull
ahead
it's gonna be humiliating if I leave the
thick pack behind but if I'm trailing a
bunch of fat here's the thing here's the
thing fat pay if I'm like come on fat
pigs look cool I wouldn't say I'm just
saying I mean thick boys dude
uh-oh I want to build my bike so you see
that fat pig you see that those are
electric bike that's a no just that one
for 13 grand
now am I eventually gonna get that yeah
I'm brown hold on Brandon why are you
gonna get a lecture it's an electric
bike you can go further Oh take it easy
see this is the problem with you you get
all crazy over the house the gt2 RS a
bike that's so annoying you're gonna do
it aren't you I know you're gonna get
out the NS works the turbo levo SL you
show your feet that does it horn I don't
know there's not defeat the purpose that
doesn't make you rock hard copy not
really dude because I don't know why it
doesn't it defeat the purpose of yeah
now hold on you can't just dismiss me
now how's the shock on that ball that
thing is [ __ ] dude that bike
frustrates me but I know thing dude Papa
yeah well I'm going up the mountain the
other day yeah 10 miles in yeah it's
exhausting yeah fun's going downhill
yeah now my legs a little tired
sometimes my fat ass my thick ass that
pig has to jump off the bike and walk up
the hill boys I can't bike up okay it's
so steep yeah but if Papa has some help
now you go I can stay on the bike and
cruise up and I can go farther and
farther and farther so instead of 10
miles under 30 40 miles yeah so I'm
burning more calories oh yeah I like the
bike hey don't think you're a man to
work out in that dough right oh dude yes
you can SATs only assisting you to stay
on the bike to go up the hills okay you
gonna sit so you you can do it and leave
it on but most Peters having a system so
he can stay on the by 13 grand hey hey
hey oh I hate to do this what oh I hate
to do this Baba man you dude we'll call
it even after this you remember when
you're stealing all that money for me
for four years but we didn't know wasn't
your fault either I want that record
fine didn't know Harry stealing all that
money sure I hate to go back all the
years and recoup that my ha ha hold on
now hold on
all I'm asking ya
hey hey man that's not cool you said it
was a live deal that's a [ __ ] big
chunk of change dude I gotta make 26
grand or four to $13,000 Mike dude I
hate to be shitty why if you don't buy
me that bike and you hire lawyer what
route you want to go down look do this
come on
right we're partners give me the bike I
you can't just ask for a $13,000 bike so
casually I'm asking for it give junior
cred go
chin order what you're not ready you
said you're gonna get it there you have
to get a little better on the mechanical
bike they have an XL to XL all right
that's a car would you date Chin's stop
doing this man
to the credit card uh-huh the whole
chain no good two attacks that's gotta
be at least 15 grand now I gotta make 30
grand dude you want pay back the money
hey we're yours hey let it go I am going
to for 15 grand come on man
see I drank last night now I'm drinking
look I'm becoming you last night
yeah I don't drink it I only drink that
in the studio only here I used to only
drink now it's do a stand-up I broke
into the 23 year old you dick out mmm
got 23 old whiskey I'll tell you what
that's 49 so we're right under 15 taxes
$1,300 yeah dudes crazy [ __ ] it's a
beautiful now odds all odds of beating
that bike for the end of the year I
don't know dude because I'm thinking
bout my brother coming out he needs a
bike maybe you can use the Stumpjumper I
get this you're looking for any excuse
you need I know the problem with you is
I know you're gonna get it because when
once again once it's in there dude it
can't get it out you my promise once
it's in there it will never leave till
it's a calmness right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]